ما زاد عن حده انقلب ضده هذا ما يحدث ايضا
عند تناول مسكنات الصداع النصفي بشكل مفرط
التحذير اطلقه وطباع صعب مؤكدين ان
المتاعب ستزيد ويصبح الصداع اكثر شتاء ليس
هذا فقط بل ان مثل هذه الادويه التي تحتوي
على مواد افيونيه تعد مشكله بشكل خاص
لانها ترفع خطر ادمانها من قبل المرضى
الجمعيه الالمانيه لطب الاعصاب توصلت لهذه
النتيجه وشددت على ضروره الالتزام بجرعات
ادويه الصداع النصريه المحدده من قبل
الطبيب
[موسيقى]
الدراسه تقول ان الافراط في تناول مسكنات
وادويه الصداع يجعل الصداع اكثر شده الى
طبيا هذا دقيق
اكيد طبعا الافراز في استخدام المسكنات
الالم يؤدي الى قله فاعليتها فكلما قلت
فاعليه الادويه التي تستخدم لاي كان من
الامراض
وموضوعنا اليوم الصداع سيؤدي بالنتيجه الى
تفاقم المرض لانها تصبح غير فاعله وتبقى
الادويه كلها في المحصله النهائيه هي مواد
كيميائيه تعمل باسلوب معين بس دكتور محمد
يعني معظم ادويه الصداع او الادويه اللي
بتخفف من الم الصداع الراس هلا ما بدنا
نحكي اسمائها لغرض الدعايه لكن دائما ناخذ
حبتين من هذا الدواء الفلاني هل ممكن انه
احنا نصير ناخذ مثلا حبه ولا المساله مش
هيك بالتخفيف من هو المصطلح العلمي
يعني الصداع الناتج عن الافراط في استخدام
المسكنات الالم وعليه في هذه الحاله تصبح
مسكنات الالم غير فاعله اوكي نوقفها لحين
ما يعيد الجسد او الجسم استعداد للاستقبال
هذه المواد ونبدا مثل ما تفضلتي يفضل
نعطيها بالضروره القصوى حبه او حبتين مع
بعض حسب نوع الاسم طبعا اللي انت ما تحبين
الذكر الاسماء فما راح اذكر اسماء طيب ما
الحل دكتور في حال الشعور المتكرر بالصداع
النصفي او الصداع التوتري ونتجنب هذه
الادويه الصداع ينقسميه الرئيسيه صداع
اولي اللي هم اللي اشرت لهم صداع الشقيقه
والصداع التوتري وذني يمثلون الغالبيه
العظم والصداع والصداع الثانوي الناتج عن
الامراض معينه هذا الصداع اللي هو التوتري
والصداع الشقيقه في الغالب هو يصير فئه
العمريه الشابه وفي الغالب يكون مع بعض
مع بعض انا حبيت اليوم اتكلم بشكل اوسع
اذا تسمحون انتم مثلا عن موضوع هذا عن
موضوع الشقيقه صداع النصفي لانه هو اكثر
شيوعا في الفئات الشابه من سن 12 سنه الى
سن 60 سنه ومعظم الفئات العمريه الان مع
العصر الحديث مع الحداثه ومع
في في جانب ماكو جيل محدد لكن في استقبال
اسري يعني يعني تقريبا اكثر من نصف المرضى
من الصداع النصفي الشقيقه تجد عندهم تاريخ
اسري
[موسيقى]